voilà et on va prendre tout de suite à
nouveau la direction de Kiev pour
écouter la conférence de presse
conjointe
uekraine on voit ici à l'image donc
Charles Michel la présidente de la
Commission européenne et
le président
ukrainien volo 2000-zélinski vous voyez
donc ces personnalités ici à l'image je
vous le rappelle un sommet uekraine
c'est tenu aujourd'hui à Kiev en
présence donc de la présidente de la
Commission européenne du président du
Conseil européen du chef de la
diplomatie des 27 et d'une quinzaine de
commissaires il s'agit pour les 27
d'offrir des perspectives à l'Ukraine je
ne sais pas si on va pouvoir écouter à
présent cette conférence conjointe
voilà on n'a pas encore accès au son en
tout cas je vous le disais une
conférence de presse conjointe et sur le
point
d'être donné en réalité cette conférence
de presse s'est tenue déjà il y a deux
heures mais pour des raisons de sécurité
elle ne nous est pas parvenu jusqu'à
présent en tout cas vous allez à présent
pouvoir l'écouter vous le savez
l'Ukraine et candidate à l'Union
européenne et il s'agit aujourd'hui pour
les 27 de réaffirmer son soutien à cette
candidature même si on le sait le
processus sera évidemment très long au
grand dame de Kiev qui souhaite
accélérer ce processus de d'adhésion à
l'Union européenne donc on a perdu à
présent l'image on y reviendra sans
doute d'ici quelques minutes on va
maintenant
bon donc à nouveau la connexion avec
donc cette conférence de presse
conjointe on va écouter le président
zelemski
notre défense la Russie et c'est de
modifier la situation sur le front à son
avantage et pour ne pas la laisser faire
et il est important
d'élargir les possibilités de livraison
d'armes en provenance de nos partenaires
et plus les armes que nous avons une
portée supérieure mieux notre artillerie
et approvisionner plutôt les chars
occidentaux se mettent en œuvre en
Ukraine plus renforce plus forte notre
défense anti-aérienne plutôt l'agression
russe prendra fin et mieux sera assuré
la sécurité européenne la liberté de
l'Europe de l'Ukraine et du monde entier
je tous ceux qui comprennent cette
situation et qui nous aide nous tous en
Ukraine je remercie l'Union européenne
donnons avoir accordé une tranche
supplémentaire de 500 millions d'euros
dans le cadre de la facilité européenne
pour la paix la mission
de l'Union européenne pour
former nos militaires qui a été mise en
place c'est aussi très
utile nous allons pouvoir former ainsi
cette année 30 000 militaires et nous
remercions la mission pour le
financement de 45 millions
et nous voulons souligner l'importance
de la formule pour la paix et à nos
arrêts la déclaration conjointe à
l'issue de ce sommet pour
montrer le soutien à la formule pour la
paix et l'organisation du sommet pour la
paix elle la formule ukrainienne pour la
paix c'est un plan précis qui permet de
renouveler la sécurité européenne
commune détruite à part l'agression
russe nous avons abordé la question du
renforcement des sanctions contre la
Russie et nos attentes en ce qui
concerne le dixième paquet de sanctions
nous avons
abordé également la question des
missiles heureuses la question des
sanctions individuelles
la possibilité de renforcer le suivi
pour que personne ne puisse contourner
les sanctions
et
pour ne pas affaiblir les sanctions en
cours
en début des spéculations que nous
voyons dans certains pays même parmi
l'Union européenne les membres de
l'Union européenne à nous avons parlé
des sanctions juste pour
rétablir la justice pour tous ceux qui
ont souffert à cause de l'agression de
la Russie nous avons aussi
établi un mécanisme de droit qui
permettrait de tenir un responsable tout
ce qui sont responsables du crime
d'agression russe nous avons parlé aussi
de la possibilité de geler les actifs
russes pour qu'ils puissent être utilisé
pour
reconstruire l'Ukraine nous avons bien
sûr parler de notre avancement sur le
parcours pour adhérer à l'Union
européenne et je tiens à souligner que
malgré la grande guerre d'envergure
72% de
[Musique]
engagements dans le cadre de l'accord
d'associations ont été remplies nous
avons rencontré les membres de la
Commission européenne et notre
déclaration commune
par le commencement des négociations en
vue d'adhésion dans les délais les plus
bref possible et nous avons abordé les
aspects avec la Commission européenne et
le Conseil européen notre objectif est
de commencer les pour parler de cette
année
c'est un objectif c'est notre devoir je
dirais même et le sommet d'aujourd'hui
nous a permis d'atteindre le progrès de
l'Ukraine sur le parcours vers le marché
intérieur de l'Union européenne nous
avons établi un plan d'action qui
permettra à le de devenir le membre de
l'Union européenne de fait dans les
secteurs que ce soit l'énergie les
sports le domaine financier douanier et
autres donc ces deux jours d'intégration
et de la trajectoire européenne
inquiète ont porté leurs fruits les
résultats sont positifs et ceci
permettra de se rapprocher
vers lui il y a un milliard d'euros pour
le la reconstruction rapide
et la décision qui concerne le dixième
paquet de sanction contre l'agresseur il
y a la déclaration commune pour
commencer les négociations en vue
d'adhésion le plus rapidement possible
il y a aussi la conclusion de la
nécessité et de la mise en œuvre de la
formule
ukrainienne pour la paix et la nécessité
de tenir le sommet pour la paix je vous
remercie pour votre soutien
notre peuple notre état vous est
reconnaissant gloire à l'Ukraine
déclaration du président du Conseil
européen
il y a deux choses qui sont claires
en tout le message le message pour vous
et pour le peuple crinien
l'Union européenne pour ceux qui rendra
de toutes les façons possibles
nous sommes pas intimidés ils ne seront
pas intimidés par le Kremlin
nous sommes une seule famille
l'avenir de l'Ukraine est au sein de
l'Union européenne
les Ukrainiens fait un choix clair un
choix de liberté de démocratie
et de faire partie de l'Union européenne
et aussi c'est des sciences très clair
votre votre avenir est avec nous dans
notre Union européenne
votre dessin et notre destin
nous sommes là à vos côtés monsieur le
président
Vladimir c'est un moment très important
vous êtes un symbole de votre peuple on
refléter le courage du peuple crânien
notre soutien était là depuis le départ
et nous allons continuer
nous avons
aidé à hauteur de presque 60 milliards
d'euros que ce soit des adminaires que
ce soit les aides aux infrastructures
aux hôpitaux
et nous voulons vous aider aussi sur le
champ de bataille
nous avons
importé une aide à tout de 12 milliards
d'euros à l'adminitaire
dans les formations aussi
nous allons former donc de nombreux
militaires supprimés cette année
d'ici 2020 humanitaires
et de protection civile
de millions d'ukrainien ont fui la
guerre en cherchant refuse de sécurité
et je voudrais exprimer en plus sincère
à tous les pays qui ont aidés c'est
famille ses enfants ces femmes
qui les juridaient de toutes les façons
possibles dans ce pays
c'est un symbole de notre solidarité
européenne
nous allons continuer à augmenter la
pression sur la Russie pour mettre fin à
cette guerre
de sanctions
mais nous devons faire plus et nous
allons faire plus
un design paquet est en cours de
préparation
pour aller encore plus loin
des sanctions fonctionnent nous avons
frappé l'économie russe
nous avons fait en sorte que la Russie
n'est plus des technologies très
importantes
la Russie doit être retenu coupable des
crimes humains qu'elle a perpétré sur le
sol du craignant
l'Ukraine l'Union européenne vont
continuer de travailler ensemble pour
que là aussi soit coupable
donc nous devons avoir des mécanismes
appropriés
nous allons faire créer un centre
international qui va s'occuper donc de
l'agression russe en Ukraine
en plus de la responsabilité
cela n'a fait que sens que la
Russie
pour aussi reconstruire ce que la Russie
a détruit
mesdames messieurs
l'Ukraine et l'Union européenne nous
avons un but en commun maître fin à
cette gare
on peut en conservation de le respect de
la souveraineté ukrainienne
et la réforme
je travaillais activement avec les
Ukrainiens sur un programme de paix on
dit volet
avec un semis de la paix
de l'Union européenne
ont pris des heures très importantes
pour l'Ukraine
tous les efforts la progression
prise par le crâne pour lutter contre la
corruption aussi
nous voulons voir donc
une amélioration parce que toutes ces
réformes contractions aident les
citoyens
ukrainiens nous allons aider l'Ukraine
sur tout le long de ce parcours
pour que les femmes
puissent tout le potentiel de ces
accords en accord de libre-échange aussi
nous voulons faire en sorte que
l'Ukraine puisse reparti du marché
européen le plus amené un possible c'est
un pas en avant pour faire ça que
l'Ukraine et l'Europe se rapproche
cher président Charles
est là avec vous aujourd'hui demain et
pour tout le temps qu'il sera nécessaire
ils sont toujours à vos côtés
pour reconstruire une prospère
sur notre parcours commun européen
car nous ne pouvons pas avoir une Europe
sûre tant qu'on appelle une crème sur
l'Ukraine et l'Union européenne l'Union
européenne et l'Ukraine
vive l'Europe
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci désolé
à Kiev
jeudi soir que l'Ukraine c'est un modèle
d'inspiration pour l'Europe et ce matin
j'ai une raison de plus pour voir le
dire
j'ai pu le premier sont dans un dans un
bureau de poste
pour des ampoules LED
ça fait partie de notre front national
international pour réduire la
consommation énergétique
cela fait aussi partie des de la
donation de 15 millions d'ampoules
nous savons que nous pouvons aussi en
fournir 35 millions
c'est incroyable de voir que dès qu'on a
fait au bout de trois jours 750
000 citoyens ukrainiens montaient dans
un bureau de poste le plus proche ont
échangé leur ancien ampoule pour une
ampoule LED
pour faire partie de ceux qui vont
travailler pour la sécurité énergétique
et je pense que c'est un symbole
car après cette visite
dans ce bureau de poste
montre la réalité du quotidien
que vous que vous vivez tous les jours
que la Russie
souffre d'une défaite stratégique mais
que l'Ukraine
est résistante et pas son avenir vers
l'Union européenne
le fait que nous sommes ici
pour le 24e sommet
Ukraine Union européenne
au milieu d'une guerre
nous sommes ici nous parlons nous
discutons et nous créons l'avenir de
l'Ukraine au sein de l'Union européenne
et bien cela vaut plus que tous les
discours du monde
ce que vous avez fait très dangereux
c'est une réalité il faut agir
maintenant sur le terrain commençons
avec l'énergie par exemple
ce chiffre de 50 millions que nous avons
un distribué dans tout le pays
nous allons réussir
à économiser l'énergie qui va lancer
d'un réacteur nucléaire on peut faire
tellement de façon si simple simplement
en remplaçant des ampoules avec des
meilleures ampoules
les générateurs sont très importants en
ce moment
on fait en sorte que c'est continue
d'être approvisionné
donc nous allons
fournir de nombreux générateurs
faire en sorte que tout fonctionne
au début de la guerre
c'était
l'Ukraine qui exportait de l'électricité
à l'Union européenne et maintenant c'est
l'inverse
et oui nous avons donné deux gigabat
d'électricité dont vous avez besoin
avec l'aide
de tous les États membres
nous allons faire preuve donc de la
solidarité européenne
ça aussi pour une reprise rapide et dès
maintenant pour réparer les dégâts
causés par les bombes de Poutine
aux infrastructures on fait partie
mais réparer les infrastructures les
routes les hôpitaux les bâtiments est un
travail quotidien
c'est pour ça que nous devons conseiller
avec une reprise rapide
cela fait partie du point c'est le plus
gros de reconstruction
je suis heureux de dire que le premier
milliards fourni
entre l'Union européenne et qui vont
commencer tout de suite
que la reprise est immédiate
bien sûr l'aide à l'économie
dont pays les salaires il faut payer
aussi pour faire en sorte que l'économie
continue
pour l'instant l'Union européenne
pour l'instant l'Union européenne a
fourni cinquantaine de milliards d'euros
pour aider cela fait partie de l'aide au
budget aussi
sont les routes qui permettent aux biens
ukrainien d'aller au sein de l'Union
européenne de façon plus rapide
25% du PIB de l'Ukraine était transporté
à travers ses routes de solidarité
de 20 milliards d'euros
nous allons continuer ce programme
un accès sans taxe joignable au marché
pour que les biens puissent venir au
sein de l'Union européenne comme c'était
le cas l'année dernière ce sera le cas
cette année
donc aussi faire en sorte que l'Ukraine
n'est pas payé le prix pour ce programme
on parlait de beaucoup de choses à ce
sommet à ce sommet comment faire payer
la Russie pour la destruction brutale
qui est en train de causer
son travail quelles sont les différentes
options
doit payer doit être tenu pour
responsable nous sommes en train
d'accumuler les preuves de ces crimes de
guerre
nous avons des magistrats en place
qui sont en train de regarder
quels sont institutions nécessaires
et pour nous il est important d'avoir la
volonté politique de faire payer la
Russie pour ce qu'elle a fait à
l'Ukraine
[Musique]
très fort à cause des sanctions que nous
avons imposées le deuxième paquet de
sanctions est en cours
mettre en place ici le 24 février
c'est un paquet très important
le plan de se concentrer encore une fois
sur les technologies sur les
technologies
que la Russie n'aurait pas utiliser pour
la gare c'est à dire nous ont regardé
façon plus approfondie sur les
composantes qui ont été trouvées par
exemple dans les drones pour nous
aucune disponibilité que n'est pas
disponible n'est pas cette technologie à
sa disposition bien de rendre par
exemple iraniens aussi nous regardons
tout ça
nous allons aussi faire en sorte de
couper les voies de traverses
à propos de avoir des propositions en ce
sens aussi
aussi nous allons nous concentrer
sur l'Ukraine
votre détermination est incroyable
j'ai de nombreuses réformes
pour
pouvoir suivre les recommandations sans
oublier la gare que vous combattez
contre un agresseur
on va continuer de vous aider pour
chaque pas vous en parler en détail
au-delà de réformes
il est important aussi de mettre bien en
place le tout et je sais que vous soyez
en ce sens aussi
et
vos efforts sont écrits dans le rapport
qui sera fourni notamment d'ici en
automne
monsieur le Président je suis confiant
confiante que vous allez continuer
car vous savez ce qui est bon pour votre
pays
et ça réforme permettront de faire
entrer l'Ukraine dans notre système de
démocratie libre
merci beaucoup
vous avez parlé hier
des sanctions qui diminuaient
quelles sont les acquises pour ceux qui
veulent vulnérabilité que cette façon de
détourner les sanctions
[Musique]
et une question un peu plus militaire
du les pertes
quelle est votre stratégie
des troupes
je vous remercie pour cette question
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne la
politique des sanctions
c'est notre deuxième jour de discussion
nous en parleons et nous souhaitons que
la Russie n'est pas la possibilité de
faire renaître son complexes
industriels militaire
et les sanctions sont en place pour cela
nous comprenons très bien combien il y
avait de missiles de produits avant
l'agression d'envergure et nous voyons
qu'elle est la situation grâce aux
sanctions aux sanctions européennes et
aux sanctions américaines et autres il
est donc très important que les Russes
ne trouvent pas la possibilité de
contournement de ces sanctions car ils
essaient de le faire ils font avec
l'aide d'autres pays
et il est important que les sanctions
soient respectées nous avons une
plateforme qui
regroupe à tous les preuves et nous les
transmettons et nous voulons que tout le
monde le sache il réagissent ensuite les
détails ce qui concerne ces programmes
d'armement au domicile nous avons les
détails et monsieur le président
Jean-Michel madame la Présidente
Ursula vont dire là ont abordé certains
aspects il y a aussi les problématiques
des drones etc mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que nous suivons au jour le
jour tout ceci et c'est vrai que cela ne
déçoit quand nous avons des pays qui se
disent non partenaires mais qui
financièrement se trouve être partenaire
de la Russie dans cette guerre donc il
est très important pour nous de faire
transmettre ces messages et dans l'Union
européenne et
aux Etats-Unis pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
contournement ensuite nous voyons le
domaine de l'énergie nucléaire la Russie
c'est un pari de notre centre
nucléaire où il y a six unités et madame
la Présidente a bien dit que nous notre
un rapprochement est aussi énergétique
et nous étions exportateurs d'énergie et
d'électricité avant l'agression russe et
après les frappes sur notre système
énergétique nous sommes devenus
importateurs nous importons
l'électricité et heureusement dieu merci
on nous aide pour qu'on puisse avoir de
l'électricité mais les Russes se sont
emparés de 6 unités de la centrale
nucléaire et ils ont
pris la centrale non
nos employés de cette centrale nos
ukrainiennes c'est une sorte de
d'esclavage contemporain car il oblige
notre personnel ukrainien a travaillé
sur place ils prennent en otage les
membres de leur famille
et il déporte même certains en Russie
c'est arrivé au personnel ukrainien sur
la centrale nucléaire des Aborigine nous
avons des preuves et il y a par exemple
des représentants de roses atomes qui se
rendent clairement sur cette centrale
nucléaire c'est donc du terrorisme et
de l'esclavage moderne que nous décrions
nous
[Musique]
nous allons nous battre aussi longtemps
que possible non
considérons que backmouth et notre
forteresse
nos héros qui sont tombés sur le chant
de bataille de bakkmouth sont devrait
héros si elle est armes de longue portée
sont livrés
nous pourrons non seulement libérer
backmouth mais nous allons pouvoir
découper donne basse qui a été
occupé en 2014 nous avons une idée
précise de quoi nous avons besoin et
nous sommes reconnaissants à tous les
pays qui sont de nos côtes de notre côté
question suivante
chaîne de télévision nous Ukraine je
vous remercie je vous pose une autre
question monsieur le président
le crâne
rempli c'est engagements
est-ce que
à l'Union européenne si tous les
engagements sont remplis peu accepter
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine si l'Ukraine est
en état de guerre et ensuite nous voyons
la Hongrie qui souvent va à
contre-courant des décisions
prises par l'Union européenne y a-t-il
d'autres mécanismes pour approuver des
décisions
à l'intérieur de l'Union européenne et
maintenant nous avons des renseignements
qui arrivent
sur ce qui peut nous attendre à quoi
devons-nous nous préparer en vue de cet
anniversaire du 24 février
les efforts fournis par l'Ukraine
nous allons la commission
européen nous devons regarder le rapport
de la commission et pendant une décision
unanime c'est comme ça que ça marche
nous sommes confiants
car il y a une volonté politique
de la part de crème de mettre en place
toute la réforme nécessaire mais bien
sûr
ce processus est un niveau des États
membres au niveau unanime
donc d'ici la fin de l'année
le Conseil européen devra regarder le
tout et regarder quels sont les
prochaines étapes à faire pour
l'accession ensuite deuxièmement
unanimité
depuis un an et c'est un fait
apprendre les décisions unanime pour un
début de crâne autant que possible
le support sanctionner la Russie et donc
9 paquets de sanctions unanime à chaque
fois
c'est très important
on l'a dit
nous devons une Française discuter aussi
pour le 10e volet de sanction mais au
niveau de lieu mais aussi de nos alliés
pour avoir une connexion la plus grande
possible pour autant que possible et
éviter
que la Russie puisse contourner les
sanctions
et donc le procès d'acceptation
n'est pas avec des dates ligiles rigides
mais avec des objectifs à atteindre pour
améliorer une situation dans le pays
candidat
pour donc ensuite pouvoir faire partir
des négociations et ensuite de
l'acceptation quand on regarde
l'histoire de l'Union européenne il y
avait six États membres
27 aujourd'hui
il y a 21 histoires différentes de
négociation et d'acceptation au sein de
l'Union européenne
et cela montre que ce n'est pas une
seule mesure unique pour tout le monde
mais que cela dépend du pays candidat et
comment le pays avance
je veux dire que je suis vraiment
impressionné
je dois vous dire bravo pour la qualité
la vitesse et la précision
à laquelle vous êtes en train d'avancer
et vous êtes un pays en guerre
pendant que vous êtes en guerre tant que
vous défendez votre pays contre
l'agresseur
vous êtes en mesure
de faire tous les pas nécessaire pour
avancer
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai mérite et je
vous dis vraiment bravo
ensuite les prochaines étapes
il y aura un rapport de la commission
aux États membres
mais il est important pour nous ici en
automne
donc un rapport pour tous les pays qui
veulent faire partie de l'Union
européenne
nous devons montrer donc des données et
des faits et la mise en place sur le
terrain
comment et à quel niveau a été fait ce
progrès et comme je le dis la Commission
est toujours là pour aider
comme si on a beaucoup d'expérience au
sein de ce processus
pour la Commission a toujours accompagné
les pays qui un jour ou l'autre ont
rejoint l'Union européenne
énormément pour avoir ce rapport en
automne
je vous remercie beaucoup pour cette
question à quoi devons-nous nous
préparer nous sommes en train de nous
préparer nous nous préparons déjà
moi nos militaires nos services de
renseignement considèrent que la
pression sera augmentée à l'est de notre
pays la Russie peut prendre sa revanche
là où elle n'a pas réussi avant et elle
veut le faire à l'est elle veut
s'emparer de l'Est de notre pays notre
objectif est de ne pas la laisser faire
et pour cela nous devons renforcer nos
forces armées avec l'armement nécessaire
nous pensons que toutes les chances sont
de notre côté
non voulons aussi
garder bien à l'esprit que la Russie
veut prendre sa revanche et notamment
après ces tentatives échoué l'automne et
avant vous comprenez de quels axes il
s'agit et la résilience de nos gars
là-bas dépend aussi des armes et puis de
la motivation et la motivation nous est
transmises et non seulement par nos
partenaires mais aussi par l'esprit qui
règne à l'intérieur de notre pays au
début de notre
année au début de cette guerre il y
avait une motivation très forte dans
tous nos rangs tout le monde se sentait
en guerre maintenant je vois que docker
à certains endroits
se repose un peu et je pense que c'est
une sorte de faiblesse et je m'adresse
tout d'abord au journaliste et tout
d'abord au journaliste
ukrainien
unicé vous le plus rapidement possible
pour renforcer cet esprit le moral pour
que tout le monde comprenne bien que
notre pays est en guerre nous devons
tous nos souvenirs comment tout ceci
avait commencé notre objectif est de ne
pas permettre à la réussite de prendre
sa revanche ne pas laisser l'invasion se
faire à nouveau je souligne que je pense
que toutes les chansons de notre côté
pour y arriver mais nous sommes tous en
guerre et cette guerre n'est pas
terminée
donc cet esprit le moral et la
motivation
dépendent de chacun d'entre nous nous
devons ne pas disperser notre attention
mais nous devons bien garder à l'esprit
la question la plus importante c'est que
notre pays est en guerre et bien voilà
ça cet esprit
que puis-je dire nous ne pourrons pas
remporter la victoire sans cet esprit et
sans la victoire l'Ukraine n'existera
plus et tout est entre nos mains nous
sommes prêts
j'espère que vous aussi vous êtes prêts
et encore une question la dernière
question Radio France
très important c'est un moment
historique vous savez les journalistes
on va sur les lignes de front nous
allons à baroute
et on a vu la réalité de la guerre ce
qui se passe en l'Ukraine est un
massacre
et l'Ukraine n'ont pas de temps il faut
accélérer le calendrier ma question
un jeune dame tout à l'heure c'est y
a-t-il aujourd'hui une date ou en tout
cas une échéance c'est important les
échéances pour donner espoir craignant
très important savoir est-ce que vous
allez commencer
rapidement en 2023 des négociations dans
le cadre en vue de l'intégration de
l'Ukraine
une question pour vous monsieur est
volodiumski vous étiez à Washington vous
avez fait un discours historique au
Congrès seriez-vous prêt à venir à
Bruxelles capitale de cette Europe pour
venir faire un discours et rappeler
l'attachement qui est le vôtre vis-à-vis
de cette Europe voilà merci
merci beaucoup sur le sur le premier
point soyez absolument convaincu
absolument convaincu de l'unité sans
faille de l'Union européenne la totale
internationale Union européenne a
soutenir l'Ukraine et s'il y a une
coordination et une constatation qui est
constante qui est permanente qui est
pratiquement quotidienne depuis la
première minute de déclenchement de
cette invasion généralisée c'est bien
parce que nous mesurons bien que l'on
doit en permanence apprécier avec des
partenaires Ukrainiens comment on agit
pour supporter l'Ukraine dans toutes les
dimensions possibles on en a de nouveau
parler beaucoup aujourd'hui et comment
on agit pour sanctionner autant qu'il
est possible pour avoir un impact la
Russie premièrement deuxième élément sur
l'adhésion moi j'ai un peu de mémoire et
je me souviens qu'il y a quelques mois
je pense à la situation avant l'été dans
la foulée de la demande d'adhésion
réunion européenne exprimée par
l'Ukraine il y avait il tombait sur le
plan européen du scepticisme
des doutes soient capacité d'octroyer le
statut de candidat et je sais que
quelques semaines avant le Conseil
européen du mois de juin il y avait
cette atmosphère de doute et de
d'impression qu’on y arriverait pas on
l'a fait on a été capable à une limite
au mois de juin de prendre cette
décision qu'effectivement être
historique était là à la hauteur de
l'histoire nous sommes en train d'écrire
d'une volontiers au départ du continent
européen il y a dans le même temps
aujourd'hui avec le président ukrainien
avec ses équipes on a pu faire l'état
d'avancement et d'après on a commission
que moi avons dit avec clarté avec nexté
que nous saluons pas seulement les
efforts également les progrès qui ont
été déjà réalisés en quelques mois par
la partie
ukrainienne et vous l'avez compris c'est
un langage de vérité et de transparence
et je crois que la confiance elles se
sont sur la vérité la transparence vers
le peuple ukrainien dans quelques mois à
peine la commission établira un premier
rapport oral et puis un rapport après
l'été et comme prison de conseil
européen je vous indique qu'avant la fin
de
ce sujet ne sera pas occulté il sera mis
sur la table du conseil et les États
membres auront apprend attitude par
rapport à cela donc d'un mot vous l'avez
compris nous sommes très très conscients
de notre responsabilité commune
collective nous savons que les décisions
que l'on prend que l'on prend pas
aujourd'hui elles ont des conséquences
pour les prochaines décennies elles
auront un impact pour la sécurité pour
la démocratie pour la liberté sur le sol
européen c'est pour ça que vous avez
face à vous des responsables très
déterminés
je vous remercie pour cette question
au début de la guerre
moi je vous dis que dès le début de
cette guerre
je
suis et je me déplace et il y a la
question des armements
la société le voit et il y a des
décisions fondamentales je me suis
rendue aux États-Unis et c'est ça la
raison et nous sommes très
reconnaissants
aux États-Unis pour ce soutien
en ce qui concerne le jour d'aujourd'hui
il a formule de la paix est une arme une
arme différente mais c'est une arme
également et les armements de longue
portée
changeront le cours de la guerre nous
sommes certains de notre victoire mais
elle arrivera plus vite avec ce type
d'armement et
l'Ukraine le sait elle a réussi le sait
et Bruxelles le sait
je suis sincèrement
reconnaissant
une trentaine
de pays
parmi lesquels la plupart nous
soutiennent dès le début par conséquent
les deux points qui étaient prioritaires
pour m'en auparavant reste
prioritaire tout d'abord c'est la
reconnaissance que
qui prouve l'Ukraine vis-à-vis des
leaders de l'Europe et des dirigeants de
l'Union européenne et le point numéro 2
ce sont les armes et j'espère que ces
deux points pourront être confirmés par
les leaders de l'Union européenne et
nous allons donc nous réunir
ce sera
inévitable et ne sera pas remis en cause
nous avons beaucoup de questions et
quand les questions sont posées à
Charles Michel et à moi nous hésitons
même qui répond en premier et c'est vrai
que
j'ai très envie de
le faire mais il y a des risques
liés à la volonté de
la Russie de prendre sa revanche donc
oui si je me déplace les risques
existent mais c'était prioritaire donc
voilà je dis que j'en ai envie merci
beaucoup de cette conférence de presse
voilà donc pour cette conférence de
presse conjointe entre donc le président
ukrainien vous l'audières zellenski le
président du Conseil européen Charles
Michel et la présidente de la Commission
européenne
Ursula van der la hyène à l'issue donc
de ce sommet
Ukraine consacrée en grande partie à la
candidature de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne en bref donc vous le dis
MERCI a dit merci pour une tranche
d'aide supplémentaire de lieu de 500
millions d'euros mais aussi pour la
formation de ces militaires par les
occidentaux il affirme que 72% des
obligations de l'Ukraine dans le cadre
de l'accord d'associations avec l'UE
sont remplies et souhaite commencer les
pourparler d'adhésion des 7 années le
président du Conseil européen
Charles-Michel lui a répondu que
l'Ukraine et lieu sont une seule et même
famille l'avenir de l'Ukraine est avec
nous au sein de lieu